out there welcome in welcome to another
edition of Market takes you know there's
a lot going on this week but here on
Market takes we're going to tell you the
three most important things that you
need to be watching out for this week
one of them is the big inflation report
we've got coming out on Thursday the CPI
Consumer Price Index economists are
expecting that to rise or inflation to
pick up increase from the previous month
uh for the first time in about 13 Going
on a little more than a year over 13
months that could be big and we are
going to talk about how the market could
react we've also got some big earnings
reports from likes of Disney and UPS a
number of other companies we're going to
tell you which ones to hone in for and
what to look for in those reports and of
course you may not have known this but
the New York fed household debt and
consumer household and Consumer Debt
report is out this week as well as the
U.S consumer credit report that's out a
little later today tell you what to look
for and why those will be important for
the market for investors but also for
you and I regular folks out there so
let's talk about it listen first report
I want to talk about is the CPI consumer
price index that inflation report that's
coming out on Thursday I want to throw
some up here on your screen just to give
you an idea of what we've been seeing so
as you see this this chart goes back to
the beginning of 2022 and you see
inflation just steadily rising and
peaking in that nine percent area right
in June that was the highest inflation
had been in around 40 years a little
more than 40 years uh June 9.1 percent
year-over-year inflation and so compared
to the previous year we have seen
inflation come down every single month
since then uh into June and so now for
that July report Economist surveyed by
the Dow Jones are expecting inflation to
actually have increased to 3.3 percent
now this is important because it's going
to counteract if if inflation does
behave as expected it's going to counter
and move differently than what we have
seen for over a year and that could be a
big shake-up or a big surprise for the
market now like I said this is priced in
economists expect 3.3 inflation and
remember we're now comparing to lower
numbers than what we were in June so
that could be one reason why inflation
picks up it may not be a big reason for
concern or worry but you're going to
want to look inside the details of the
report now is this about goods or
services we've seen Goods prices kind of
consistently falling and uh Services
price is picking up how much does that
happen and how much does that continue
but we are expecting to see a change in
this pattern that we've seen for a
number of months and it's going to be a
question of how the Market deals with
that but this chart here just
illustrating the way that inflation has
behaved over the past year and
economists are expecting that we will
see that kind of reverse and inflation
pick back up how much it picks up why it
picks up what moves it higher and why
are going to be closely what you're
going to want to tune into Market takes
we'll be right here 10 a.m Eastern on
Thursday morning to break all that down
for you and talk about how it how it
relates to the Federal Reserve and what
they're planning and what they're going
to do going forward through the rest of
the year the Fed really is data
dependent now the data is going to drive
their decisions so we will see how that
report really impacts and influences
that and it's going to be all about the
details in that report and we'll break
all that down with you like I said
Thursday morning 10 a.m right here on
Market takes how will the market react
we're going to find out and we're going
to talk through that together what we
talk about next let's talk about
earnings ups and Disney are the big ones
that are coming out this week and they
will be out a little bit later coming on
on Tuesday and Wednesday so you're going
to want to watch for those out this week
we also get earnings reports from
Alibaba I think you'll want to watch
that because there's been this big story
about The Slowdown in the Chinese
economy and I think those Alibaba
earnings reports because that's a
company that has to report earnings they
are required to put those numbers out
and we will really get a real deal look
inside what's happening in China for one
of its biggest companies I will get
those reports also we get Lyft Fox
BuzzFeed coinbase palantiers some others
but I really think ups and Disney are
the two you're going to want to watch
for those are a couple companies that
have really there's stocks have
underperformed year-to-date and over the
past year UPS is up only three percent
year-to-date compared to the 17 percent
gain in the overall S P 500 over the
past one year period it's down eight
percent compared with an eight percent
rise in the S P 500 that really has
resulted from again this slowdown in
Goods that we've talked about folks
aren't buying as much not going as much
through ups but there are also a number
of other issues for UPS we saw uh just
today the company yellow one of the
largest trucking companies in the US
back I think the largest trucking
company uh risk applied for or filed for
bankruptcy protection today we have seen
FedEx had weak earnings so these numbers
from UPS are going to be very highly
watched considering where we are right
now in the economy it's going to tell us
about online shipping it's going to tell
us how those lower fuel prices if that
contributed to UPS's bottom line
affected growth summer travel all of
those things UPS is going to tell us a
lot about another company you're going
to want to watch Disney down three
percent year-to-date and down 21 over
the past one year those are going to be
watching for those Disney Plus numbers
but you're also going to want to watch
as we think about how much Americans are
traveling are they going back to theme
parks Disneyland Disney World all those
Resorts that Disney owns things like
that how much is that is has Disney been
able to benefit from this big pickup and
travel that we have seen we hear the
Americans are spending they're going out
they're very confident they're spending
their money well is Disney able to
benefit from that and are they
attracting those people is the economy
still behaving as it was those earnings
reports are going to tell us a lot about
how much they've bounced back or not so
we'll see you're going to want to watch
those Disney and UPS this week I think
going to tell us a lot about the economy
last but not least the U.S consumer
credit report is out Monday afternoon
that's today at 3 P.M check that out
we've seen continually Rising uh credit
as in more folks in the U.S taking out
debt credit but we have seen it Rising
more slowly and month over month we've
actually seen a significant deceleration
in terms of credit
I think that may have a lot to do not so
much with the demand side is in people
wanting credit it seems like folks still
want credit they still need to borrow a
lot of that money because we are seeing
credit card balances at an all-time high
but what we are seeing is you know
companies Banks saying we're not giving
out as much credit we've seen also we'll
also get the New York fed household
survey that's a quarterly report last
time it showed all-time high record
credit card debts we get both of those
but I think I want to throw a chart up
here on your screen that I think
illustrates and really talks about and
shows what we're seeing and why I want
you to watch out for these reports now
this is the latest fed senior loan
officer opinion survey the sluice report
for us cool kids out there and what you
see there is consistently as we get to
levels of the number of banks saying
they're raising their standards for
giving out credit or raising their
standards for making loans you see a
recession because Banks start to get
nervous they think oh man people aren't
going to pay this back we've got to
start tightening up and making sure we
only give credit to the most worthy
borrowers well what you see there on the
right of your screen is an unusual Trend
we've seen it kind of pick up and that
numbers stay high but not reach those 70
75 levels like we saw in the 2008 Global
Financial Crisis crisis and the Great
Recession and even in 2020 in covid
unusual for what you see usually see it
pick up and then come back down as Banks
start to kind of that worry starts to
ease what you're seeing is it's staying
high and that's unusual and really this
chart just illustrates the unusual
credit environment that we've seen where
Banks really are just raising those
standards keeping it high and they're
actually turning a lot of folks away we
saw a report actually out from the New
York fed just last week showing that
credit was the hardest to get in years
with fewer people seeking out loans a
lot of them reporting that hey you know
what I just don't think I'll get it I
don't think the bank will give it to me
so I'm not even going to bother to look
for it important to watch what's
happening at Banks and what's happening
with credit and whether folks are able
to get the credit they want and that
they feel they need so that's what
you're going to want to watch out for
this week because I think that's going
to tell you a big thing about or a lot
about what's going to happen in the
future rather than What's Happening Now
Hey listen that's going to do it for us
here on Market takes I'm your host Dion
Robert Bowen reporter at the Wall Street
Journal thanks so much for tuning in and
I hope you'll be with us next time